nous Ne remercions jamais assez Jacques
hlan et son orchestra d'entre venu nous
rappeler si belles heures elle
s'efface mais ce n'est qu'un Au revoir
pour laisser Place une très grande
vedette une très grande chanson et paris
canaille
Harry Marlou aux yeux de fill ton air
filou ces vieilles guenilles et ces guul
J'ai accepté fait pas mais c'est si c'est
gigolo les habillés sous le métro de la
Basti pour se saouler tes chupau sa fait
gueuler mais c'est si bon brin de Lil
fleur de fontaine fait des Tas de petits
tapin Qui font merveille en de raison
fait de l'oseille et deon c'est de la
cro Ver d'en ver fait des mois qu'il
sont Au vert alors ces dames ft une
raison ell F Pig et
c'est Paris Bandit Au mains qui glisse
tuas pas d'amis dans la colce dans ton
cor s de néo tu n passage mais c'est si
B holdup savon pour la chronique
traction avant pour la te un petit coup
dans le diapason Range tes c sinon tu es
bon une fmi FR Je teis mieux la toute
Derre des éditions c'est en gal mais
c'est si
bon rien un G le droit pour faire carton
la prochaine fois tu fas B
Paris j'ai bu la voix grise le long des
rues tu V cal IL y a pas d'espoir dans
Ce sont les prochaines étapes
c'est si bon tes
vagabonds te font les scènes mais sous
tes peau coulent la scène pour la romance
une illusion IL et un de l'influence mais
c'est si bon mon égaré dans les fond fré
o pousse l'amour sa pousse Encore La
Maison On A eu tort mais c'est si beau
regard perdu dans le ruisseau la rue
manger un bateau sa tangue un peu dans
l'entre c'est laborieux mais c'est si
beau ha flon flon fa et des Millions
verse ces pots qui sont des centimes ma
chanson fait la rime
condamné